you're an incredible
human being that you're involved with
this your band
ghost hounds is touring with the rolling
stones
so before we talk about your band let me
ask about that
what's that like
playing with the rolling stones
surreal just because
they're my favorite band of all time
um
the to me the greatest rock and roll
band it's not even close of all time and
you know to to share the same stage to
to be on tour and
to go out and get that energy from the
crowd
um
you know
and every night and come off stage and
later when they go on and you hear that
iconic ladies and gentlemen the rolling
stones and then
it's incredible and you know what's
what's amazing to me about the band
next year will be their 60th anniversary
60 years
and
it's it's hard to be around anything for
that long
but making music and packing stadiums
and what's amazing to me they can play a
two-hour set and it's not just that oh
that's a hit or you recognize it
it's like every song is an anthem right
yeah so
uh so it's it's it's been amazing we got
to play with them in 2019 and when they
ask us to do this uh again
um just it's just a
absolute privilege i asked you this
offline so i know you are a kind of rock
star yeah but
just me maybe i'm projecting but do you
get
nervous
such a large audience with the rolling
stones
it feels like there would be a lot of
pressure
yeah i mean you definitely don't want to
screw it up i think
um the band our band
you know is tight knit and all that
stuff and i think that you
the individual nervousness dissipates
when you go out as a group and you're
making music together
and you sort of okay we're all in this
and you know we're we're doing a thing
which is why even in sports i always
look at individual events like ice
skating or
you know anything where it's just you
out there alone yeah and that's that's
different than being uh with it with a
team and nerve-wracking so
um
i'm sure if it was me with an acoustic
guitar just going out
it would feel different but absolutely
you get
the right kind of butterflies i would
call it um
and just the energy
of playing music and having it be this
relationship and you and look i get it
i've been
to a ton of concerts where i'm like look
can we just get to the band please
but uh what's been great is just an
amazing reception
um
and we have this this uh guy named trey
nation is the lead singer is just
incredibly talented i mean
he's just uh
not only an amazing voice but just has
that charismatic thing yeah so he's
great that's fun what's it feel like
to play in front of a huge audience
what's uh what's the as a guitarist like
what's uh they feel are you lost in the
music like you almost don't
feel the audience
does it add extra energy does it ex
extra anxiety what what does it make
what's it feel like
you know stadiums are interesting just
because it's so big and cavernous
and because you know you want to protect
your ears so we use an in-ear system so
that you are a little disconnected
from the crowd because if you're playing
that loud and you're standing in front
of your amps without ear protection that
that's bad
how are you monitoring the sound are the
in-ear stuff is that producing sound or
is it strictly ear plugs no it's
producing the sound so
i like putting ear pods in and listening
to a song and you're playing to it right
it's just us playing but it protects
your ears
um
but the the energy from the crowd
when they when they get going and get
into it which knock on wood so far has
been amazing
um there's nothing like it
i mean there there's
it's uh it's just this bi-directional
thing that happens and um
i
love music was kind of music and sports
were you know kind of my first loves and
um
it's uh
yeah it's it's very difficult to
describe i think accurately
because it's like no other feeling
musically
how is it different than playing in a
garage with the band by yourself
practicing
like is is it do you do you feel like
you're creating something different
when you're when you're um
when you got the guitar and the amp and
just the sound dissipating out into and
everybody's listening was is that yeah
it's uh
listen the first time we did it and
there's nobody in the stadium first time
i ever played in the stadium and i'm
just like
i'm out there in front and just hitting
different chords and playing different
licks and i'm like
it's like i won a contest and i get to
do this
yeah but uh
you know what's different about it
and each venue is different so if you if
you
um
we went on the road with zz top a few
years ago which was incredible love
billy gibbons he's a texan
incredible person and guitar player but
you know when you're playing in like
five to seven thousand seats
it's really i mean it's you know you're
right there with them
uh with the crowd and then when you play
in an arena um for we we toured with uh
with bob seger on his last tour which
was cool played some shows with him
and again the arena like they're all
kind of packed on top of you
and it's super loud which which was cool
um i mean the crowd is stadiums is a
completely different animal
and uh
it's it's just a completely different
experience do you enjoy it versus like a
smaller room
as a guitarist
as a musician what's your favorite like
room to play the size any room that'll
have me
look i think
arenas are the perfect blend yeah if i
had to say because it's loud and you
know 20 30 000 people
but like right up yeah right up on you
stadium
look play in the stadiums with uh with
the rolling stones is it just is going
to go on the head marker somewhere is
one of the more you know i say this and
i really mean it my my life is like a
punk episode that just hasn't no one's
burst in yet yeah but
yeah it's it's as cool as you think it
is
you